hey guys i'm abby shart welcome to
Abby's kitchen as a dietitian I can tell
you there is a lot of misinformation out
there when it comes to nutrition
knowledge I mean I'm used to debunking
myths but when I start seeing these
healthy living trends turn into
catchphrases and buzzwords I actually
lose my shop so I brought along
everyone's favorite ill-informed
nutrition junkie Diet Debbie to
highlight some of the worst nutrition
buzzwords of 2016 Canada's total
superfood that's all the tail oh god
here we go ah yes the myth of a cure-all
head of kale they ate one of the
greatest marketing schemes of all time I
know most of these foods are healthy
even super healthy but superfood
insinuates that they are like a magical
cure-all for all of your mystical
problems sorry kids no food can do that
all foods have the redeeming qualities
and being healthy means getting a
balanced diet with a full range of
vitamins and minerals that you'll never
find in just one single food last week I
was so that ate so much pasta the busy I
didn't eat really good
I'm just eating go today why do we
humans love to categorize and
dichotomize everything by labeling
individual foods as good and bad we take
it out of the context of our general
healthy diet and we assign this negative
label or connotation that we later
associate with ourselves as a result we
end up feeling a ton of shame and guilt
about our eating and that is neither
healthy or very funny also research
suggests that we label foods is good or
bad we tend to crave them more so to
strip that food of any moral meaning and
you might actually find that those bad
foods that start to lose their allure no
I'm Kenny Powers [ __ ] I think eating
clean all month long so when I was a kid
I used to ask my mom to wash my grilled
cheese because the toasty bits
looked dirty to me I mean obviously now
as an adult I can look back and see the
idiocracy in this especially knowing
that brown
because flavor but this is actually what
I think about when I hear people talk
about clean eating this is the same
problem as the good food bad food
mentality and I went to town on this one
in a previous video so totally check
that out but just know I'm becoming
obsessed with Queen eating to the point
where it literally takes over your life
is definitely not a healthy place to be
just stop using the word are you really
that sugar is so inflammatory
first of all whoa this is a really big
broad topic inflammation just basically
means that there's an immune response to
something going wrong in your body and
yes I know we love to blame specific
foods or food groups as a culprit of
inflammation but we really need to look
at the bigger picture here from a
nutrition perspective yes getting a diet
rich in antioxidants will help fight
some of those symptoms of inflammation
but this is just one tiny little piece
of a very large complicated puzzle by
focusing solely on food or a food group
we could be completely masking the true
root cause of that inflammation I'm
doing a cleanse this leads to totally
detox from the holidays you should do
you know I cannot Spanish this I mean
there are so many so-called cleanses or
detox products out there all promising
to cleanse your body of all its toxins
and leave your body squeaky clean inside
and out the reality is we already have
kidneys a liver skin a digestive tract
and lungs to do exactly that we do not
need another $20 bottle of putrid green
juice to try to cleanse our body
honestly I know I'm going to get a lot
of hate mail for this but I think that
these cleanses are the most socially
accessible forms of disordered eating of
this generation if you really want to
cleanse check out my video here but
spoiler alert you're probably already
doing a lot of it copyboy shutting down
after everything
say because it's both the Debbie it's
all a bunch of fluffy words these
nutrition buzzwords are basically just
marketing schemes to get you to buy last
more shot that you don't need I know it
science is a lot less sexy than
sensationalized media headlines but I am
actually work and I'll take science over
sound bites any day so guys I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below
because I want to know what nutrition
terms and buzzwords you are sick of
hearing about also subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen
[Music]